[Musique]
super
seul
bats toi
cela
[Musique]
à quai
[Applaudissements]
comme souvent
à deux mois du stade
l'asm
[Musique]
c'est
[Applaudissements]
n'est ce pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à kehl
[Musique]
c'est votre poisson que je regardais pas
autre chose on
les mignons
j'aime bien ces petits yeux globuleux
vide alors il est à vous quand j'étais
petit j'en ai eu un mois aussi un
poisson tropical
en réalité je n'ai pas gardé longtemps
vu que chez mille chauffage à fond un
jour je suis parti et puis quand je suis
revenu il y avait plus d'eau bref je
descends ici content d'avoir pu discuter
je vais vous gardiez d'accord allô oui
allô allô oui je le fasse j'ai quelqu'un
en ligne pour vous le prenez non
les gueux raté
juste ici doni regarde faut l'amener
dans le ventre bien la canaliser
tu sens toute cette puissance toute
cette chaleur toute cette force
ouais tu l'avais bien celui là
t'as pas
[Musique]
notre photo
qu'est ce que ça donne un mort amène pas
de téléphone portable compris j'ai bien
entendu
je t'ai dit plus de portable c'est clair
à
[Musique]
you sleep
sovo bomb et it's all mac
mais moi trois cigarettes
merci dieu
ramène tes fesses ici
désormais tu es plus sur l' affaire
comme ça ça ne prendra pas avec moi
arrête ton char tu étais déjà en sursis
avec mise à l'épreuve
je t'ai envoyé dans la rue parce que tu
étais censé y faire du travail de
routine
d'ailleurs à ce propos ce gosse est à
mourir de rire tu sais ce qu'il a fait
hier il a pris un taxi pour aller dans
le bronx est plutôt que de payer la
course il a montré ton badge chauffeur
et annie poli je réquisitionne votre
véhicule il en avance franck tu sais qui
m'a raconté cette histoire
le maire le maire qui m'avait confié
vouloir me nommer chef de la police de
la ville le même maire à qui je venais
tout juste de te recommander pour me
succéder à la tête du commissariat
je comprends pas ce qui t'arrive en ce
moment celui après 30 ans de service
n'est pas que tu vas laisser soyaux
continue à nous narguer prendre le
risque de tout perdre
j'ai arrangé ça récupère ton beach
démerde toi comme tu veux j'en ai rien à
[ __ ]
mais je veux que ce commissaire bien
retrouver un petit nid des lices à sa
chérie tu célèbres
la jolie photo
fous l'camp je veux plus te voir ici
fait vous pouvez expliquer ce type que
je suis prof de pilates pas un voleur à
la tire d'ailleurs son talent en
veilleuse y voilà
on va faire un tour et à quoi là-bas si
je note et sans déconner je connais mes
droits pouvaient pas me garder
et c'est pas vrai j'y croyais moi ça
c'est pas moi c'est un bon signal en
tout cas donne moi non
jack et
jaxx
ça m'a donné la sonnette n'est toujours
pas réparé
je
mais la tâche actuelle
du vrai cuir
divoli
[Musique]
des sourds ou quoi
non qu'est ce que c'est que ça tu peux
le dire ce que c'est
des téléphones portables exactement des
portables et je t'ai dit quoique alerte
a dit on voulait plus on voulait plus
désolé j'ai entendu plus portable s'est
figé on est bien d'accord
voyons tous que la capote comme
d'habitude c'est moi le liquide tiens
il m'a tout donné tu es sûr
k
c'est tout c'est tout ce que ça mérite
plus de fric mobiway je pose pas toute
la journée pour des clopinettes donc
tant mieux puisque oui je peux plus faut
aussi que je bouffe ramène des objets de
valeur de l'or des diamants
partez merde à touba l'habituel je t'ai
déjà dit que je voulais pas de diamant
ok c'est vrai j'avais oublié ce détail
qui volera diamant c'est trop personnel
mais il faut chez démontre que sat est
égal oui n'importe quel abruti à une
autre on n'a pas une fois c'est un petit
marrante suis mort de rire qui veut
voler est ce que tu as envie
voilà ce que tu as envie je vais juste
bosser pour moi jusqu'à la fin des jours
on doit tous se rendre des comptes à
quelqu'un moi aussi je dois rendre des
comptes à quelqu'un je sais une fois
aussi tu as quelqu'un à qui tu rends des
comptes mois
gnc bol que tout retrouver mon
portefeuille je sais pas comment tu
remercier syrien parfois j'ai
l'impression que cette ville
c'est la jungle peu de gens seraient
prêts à aider à makoun serait aussi je
trouve dingue cette façon qu'a la vie de
générer des situations qui rapproche
deux individus tu vois ce que je veux
dire téléchargement steam a démasqué
merci non attends c'est moi qui t'invite
ce soir non ça me gênerait de caisse et
payer je veux pas que tu t'imagines que
j'étais rendu service par intérêt qui
n'attend rien en retour
car son écoute et on vient de me
signaler qu'il était suspecte sur la
carte de crédit qui a été volé ce matin
dans le métro tazza un resto je veux des
agents civils et des voitures banalisées
compris
je crains que votre kurt avait été
refusée ok ça c'est l'univers qui nous
dit que c'est à moi de payer non c'est
bon ça va aller j'en ai une autre à qui
ça arrive parfois il ya des sortes de
bugs ou je ne sais trop quoi
c'est plutôt gênant excusez moi monsieur
puis je vous parle en privé
bien sûr tu nous excuser minutes le nom
sur cette carte est différent de la
première que vous m'avez donné tiens
donc je sais pas quoi vous dire c'est je
vous prie de m'excuser c'est la carte
que j'utilise en général quand je laisse
un pourboire de 100 dollars mais si vous
voulez notre carte
autant pour moi c'est réglé tout à fait
être coûté réglé monsieur fujimoto ça se
prononce pour guy matte foggy matin
jeudi explique l'autre jour je rentrer
tranquillement chez moi j'étais avec
deux musiciennes mans compte on devait
être trois réussies moi je dirais je me
suis retourné il y avait ce type un peu
bizarre qui nous suivaient je peux tu
interrompre un instant je suis désolé
mais j'ai une envie pressante il bouge
pas je regarde
excusez moi
on n'avait pas eu un problème avec une
carte bancaire le client était à cette
table merci
il est parti aux toilettes les toilettes
sont pas gardées le pourboire
acquis sur ses menottes
happy quoi quoi quoi qu'est ce qui se
passe car c'est une souris non mais
piste a souri maman pas moi vers la
moitié ici l'autre a senti un petit
attroupement tout ça et je ne vois pas
bloquer son réfrigérateur
elle est partie
ça va ça va aller j'ai horreur sérieux
ma mère tu veux me tuer si je fais une
crise cardiaque qui va payer le loyer
j'ai pas prévu d'aller à l'église ce
soir alors je me disais je peux te
laisser de quoi dîner si tu veux je le
cherchais un hamburger te fatigue pas si
tu veux en berbère je peux t'en préparer
un je te laisserais au frigo rugueuse si
tu veux merci tu me dépanne raid
quelques dollars pour le bingo
je ne cautionne pas les jeux d'argent
par as tu sais que je n'aime pas que tu
fasses des paris tu veux finir comme
papa je ne parie pas jouer au bingo
c'est à l'église
d'accord mais qu'on passe sur moi pour
éponger des dettes quand tu ne seras
plus là
de ce côté là j'ai déjà bien assez donné
ça va le travail
la bourse est en hausse ce mois ci était
un brave garçon bobby
[Musique]
salue ici
oui non je sais je m'en souvenais l'uci
en fait j'étais assez loin et j'étais
prête à peine que cette étoile
c'est toi
maintenant
c'est ça fait un bail didot
cette distance
j'en fais ce que tu veux
je fais bien
il n'y a pas grand chose à dire
j'allais prendre ma pause déjeuner j'ai
essayé de taper mais jamais réussi à
joindre je sais pas si le téléphone est
écouté
ouais non c'est seulement qu'il fait
jour nouveau
vous pourrez déjeuner ensemble un de ces
quatre histoires de bavarder prendre des
nouvelles j'aurais volontiers c'est
maintenant un début
tu crois
je suis inscrit
c'est dire
félicitations c'est une super nouvelle
c'est waou
des enceintes de combien
moi
elle te dis toi
il est de tripoli
attends pas si vite comment c'est
possible on a fait ça qu'une seule nuit
réalité on a fait ça plus de 3,7
millions
ouais mais quand même on a fait ça que
cette nuit là la fosse sèche keynes il
faut s'y fie
d'abord
c'est sûr que
comment tu sais qu'il est moi
et c'est légitime comme question en quoi
tu crois que je couche avec tout les
mecs qui passent tu me proposes vite
c'était un coup d'un soir j'étais là
faire d'un soir j'ai été attrapés en ce
qui me concerne a tempêté couteuges pas
cause plus jamais la meilleure joueuse
et moi il ya un problème
tout va bien assurez-vous c'est ma
copine on ajuste un tir même un vrai
tout va bien monsieur quoi tu joues tu
me faire arrêter ou quoi l écouteront
petits bouts je te signale que c'est toi
qui est venu le chercher et n'espère pas
que je vais courir après dans toute la
ville c'est finalement tu décides ne pas
parler sa famille un tarif de faire des
films c'est pas venu chercher
j'ai fait une croix sur toi y'a pas vrai
trois mois j'étais aperçu par hasard
j'ai pensé que peut-être atteint dans
les trains de savoir que tu allais avoir
un enfant au cas où tu croiseras un jour
maintenant tout pour
ça
quand tu te plaît
misère vous avez des cigares atripla des
cigarettes vous savez j'aime autant vous
dire autre chose toi mon nom les six
mais c'est joli ça vous va ravir
[Musique]
m
non
[Musique]
c'est bon arrêtez stature
ton vieux avait des lettres
à présent ce sont les tiennes à partir
de maintenant tu bosses pour moi
[Musique]
et
mais
il
[Musique]
si je suis qui je suis il
non bobby corée voilà qui je suis juste
là je te vois toi c'est quoi un futur '
stop au nom d'anne moi c'est toi qui vas
la fermer si tu veux pas que je
t'embarque
le coût de la porte vitrée ça fait très
inspecteur harry
à vrai dire c'était ma faute c'est toi
qui m'a donné carte blanche
merci pitt c'est une des choses que
j'apprécie chez toi tu lis tu fais
toujours les choses à sa façon sans
souci tu que vont penser les gens
imagine si je devais changer maintenant
c'est moi j'ai toujours fonctionné de
cette façon je sais pas faire autrement
je pense que je pourrais faire d'autre
c'est prévu comme ensuite parce que ce
qu'on veut faire
je vais récupérer mon badge
et tant pis si pour sa joie de tuer ce
petit con
oui bonjour une petite fille toi
e
moi c'est karl karl non maman m'a dit je
pensais que c'était si tu serais au
bureau c'est qui ce gala ses carnets non
ça j'avais compris je veux savoir ce qui
fit chez nous et en plus dans mon
baignoire tu n'as pas les attendait le
bon moment ce n'est pas lui reprocher
alors bob voilà je suis je suis un ami
de ta mère oui on joue ensemble bingo
est-ce que ce cas là est ce que vous
devant bobby ce n'est pas ce que tu
crois
ça fait longtemps qu'on est amis lui et
moi je vais l'attendre pour te dire mais
il est temps qu'ils sachent aîné karl
m'a demandé dans les majeures depuis
qu'est ce qui t'es arrivé
tu as une tête de mort vivant ouais la
mort serait un soulagement qu'on partait
au merdier temavi à l'heure actuelle je
suis avec toi sans pour ça je peux me
parlait jamais une fille enceinte c'est
ça foutrait de ma gueule
je t'ai dit je suis avec toi à 100% je
t'assure que tu as mon soutien total je
suis derrière toi d'ailleurs te retourne
pas merci je suis vraiment dans la merde
montre celle qui tend à kolin non je
suis tombé dans l'escalier c'est d'une
des qu'est ce qu'il va faire elle va
garder le gamin je n'en sais rien on n'a
même pas mis cette éventualité sur le
tapis pourquoi ce qu'elle voudrait
garder un bébé qui n'aura pas de pair
surtout si les toits il lui du blé dit
lui de s'en débarrasser
tu vas te retrouver dans les couches
sales jusqu'au cou suis mon conseil fait
nécessaire avant qu'il soit trop tard il
lui a apporté
[Musique]
et tu es qui toi
il me connaît je suis un vieil ami à
elle on ami d'enfance à toi aussi tu
viendras youtube
elle a grandi au texas connard
maintenant des gaspards torche m'a
écouté petit mois au moins sept
travaillent encore ici je veux seulement
lui parler comme la moitié des types
dans ce bar les gars jouent c'est moi
qu'ils dégagent
sans rire tu as trouvé ça tout seul
allez si les scilly si tu connais ce cas
ci c'est moi ta propre fils
[Musique]
je
c'est bon on dégage ok non attendez
c'est pas à toi que je parlais
qu'est-ce que tu fiches ici
je suis désolé pour le tu sais c'est
seulement
j'étais un peu sous le choc quand tu as
dit que
il faut dire que quand on annonce ce
genre de nouvelles un garçon
tu vas faire quoi tu veux le garder
est ce que je veux le garder
c'est pas des chiens errants cause non
ça je le sais très bien je cois du
désespoir parce que je boite écouter
tout ce que j'entends c'est du vent
si tu veux pas garder le bébé je vais je
t'aiderai pour l'argent
un vrai gentleman q qu'est ce que tu
attends moi exactement
j'attends rien de toi c'est toi qui est
venu me trouver ici au capteur à oublier
je suis papa pourquoi tu voudrais avoir
ce bébé
pourquoi tu voudrais mettre au monde un
enfant avec une mère qui n'a pas les
moyens de l'élever et interminable qui
ne veut rien avoir à faire avec lui je
veux dire
moi j'essaie seulement de t&d du
comprends ça ira tu en as déjà fait
assez
on peut pas discuter avec toi faut
toujours que tu joues à la plus fine et
après tu sais j'ai dessiné je t'aurais
pas adressé la parole
et j'aurais passé mon chemin c'est
exactement ce que je disais j'essaie
simplement de prendre mes
responsabilités et aider sur ce coup là
je fais de trouver un bon médecin
d'accord et c'est moi qui en assumerait
les frais
alors qu'est ce que t'en dit
j'en dis que tu es le dernier des
connards
mais je vais y penser
à temps
comment je fais pour te joindre
t'as qu'à appeler ici
je crache dans la réserve de gomer c'est
ainsi
combien
non le souci c'est que j'ai pas
d'assurance santé
je ne veux pas de consultation gratuite
je veux pas y est ce que je dois
oui j'ai bien conscience de tout ça mais
ok et alors si je vous paie cash
on ne peut pas trouver un arrangement
allô allô
je suis passé prendre le reste de mes
affaires
tu veux bien dire quelque chose s'il te
plaît sinon quoi tu vas dire à ton
copain de me frapper
c'est un homme bien et il a besoin de
moi et moi j'ai pas besoin de toi
bien sûr que si non ça c'est ce que tu
t'imagines mais c'est toi qui s'occupent
de moi je ne veux pas que tu aies
assumer ce fardeau avec car l'on prend
soin l'un de l'autre
je vois ça fait partie de votre
arrangement avec ton pote de bingo
j'aime cet homme bobby pas comme j'aime
et on perd nico que je t'aime toi c'est
un amour différent peut-être que quand
tu rencontreras la bonne personne tu
comprendras
ça sera évident
je dois y aller écoute il aimerait
inviter à dîner de m'asseoir partir sur
de nouvelles bases
voilà son numéro il ya longtemps que
j'ai pas été aussi épanouie tu peut
paraître un peu heureux pour moi
et
mais c'est de régler ton fer à repasser
brûle pas toutes les chemises comme tu
as brûlé les miennes
salut jaxx
non aujourd'hui j'ai une tonne de trucs
à régler ça va pas être possible oui
bobic aurélie c'est toi je prends quoi
c'est comme ça que tu appelles qu'ils
doivent ou non moi c'est tommy tome qui
domine c'est ça je suis de passage chez
ma tante qui habite pas là non à bobigny
comment vas tu j'ai appris que ta mère
allait se marier
félicitations
ils me sont tombés dessus jaxx je sais
pas comment ils m'ont trouvé mais ils
m'ont trouvé
quitte à trouver les flics ils savent où
j'habite il y en avait deux partout dans
mon appart une vraie fourmilière 1
comment ils sont humains non j'en sais
rien
comment voudrais tu que je le sache
c'est peut-être tacopina quitte à
balancer non et c'est parce que je fais
du temps suivi jusqu'ici non tout
comment tu sais tu risque rien ok tu as
un plan toujours sais rien j'ai pas
réfléchi je crois que je vais faire
profil bas quelques temps les lots de
machin tu as trouvé un endroit où le
faire ouais l'hôpital m view c'est là
que je suis née ça doit être un bon
hôpital non sans l'ombre d'un doute
quand on voit ce que tu es devenu il me
faudrait 100 dollars pour payer un motel
g nulle part où aller non fine moi tu
plais comment je vais faire chez moi
j'ai pas d'argent tu entends j'ai rien
pour toi mais je déconne pas chez nulle
part où aller
non tu insistes pas de rempart on attend
tutrice de moi espèce d'enfoiré j'ai pas
besoin de toi qu'est ce que tu crois
j'ai qu'appliquer des portefeuilles et
et et tapas 20 dollars non qu'est-ce qui
tourne pas rond chez ce cos
la vie atteint quoi j'éviterais de
prendre le métro à ta place pour un taxi
way
merci
et
mais
[Musique]
et
ouais ça lui parle c'est bobby hull
bobby le gars qui t'a flancker bah ouais
est ce que est ce que ma mère est là
elle dort à tant pis ça fait rien non je
me suis rendu compte de leur qu'il était
l'outil lui que je vous verrai demain
soir au dîner d'accord
non tout va bien je te remercie allemand
mais
[Musique]
il
je suis lucie pourquoi tu parle tout bas
c'est débile de chuchoter si c'est pour
cogner à ma porte comme un dingue
je suis passé de dire que qu'on avait
rendez-vous demain à 14 heures donc
j'espère que c'est bon pour toi
il est 3 heures du mat là donc je te
verrai dans à peu près 11 heures
d'accord la prochaine fois passé un coup
de fil
ah non c'est vrai t'as pas jamais toi
lui s'y attends attends j'ai eu une
soirée difficile tu veux bien me laisser
entrer une minute pour prendre un verre
je reste pas longtemps promis on est
cerné aucun doute aurais pas remarqué
sans déconner je peux entrer rien qu'une
minute c'est que
j'ai pas d'autre endroit où aller s'il
te plaît
rien qu'une minute
doré une cigarette je fume pas je suis
enceinte
tu veux toujours voir quelque chose oui
je veux bien ce coach te plaît
tu as envie d'en parler parler de quoi
de la misère dans laquelle tu croupis la
misère dans laquelle je croupis vous
parlez tous comme ça au texas comment tu
sais que je viens du texas je sais d
autres trucs
dans ce cas monsieur je sais deux ou
trois trucs faut que tu m'explique
pourquoi tu es venu frapper à ma porte
en plein milieu de la nuit
j'ai été expulsé
je vois
je peux te poser une question
l'espèce d'homme des cavernes au bar
c'est ton mec pourquoi t'es jaloux
curieux plus tôt non il n'y a rien entre
nous enfin je veux dire
plus maintenant mais disons qu'il il
continue à veiller sur moi c'est plus un
grand frère qu'autre chose d'ailleurs il
te tuerais certainement s'il avait été
là à plus forte raison si je savais que
c'est toi qui m'a mise en cloque il au
courant pour
pourquoi toutes ces questions si j'ai
deux commères j'en sais rien simplement
on se ressemble pas vraiment lui et moi
donc je me demandais ce que 7000 hat
avait pu me je veux dire si c'est ça ton
genre d'homme pourquoi
laisse tomber d'accord t'es en train de
me demander pourquoi j'ai passé la nuit
avec toi
ouais
à vrai dire ça fait trois mois que je me
pose la même question
c'est à cause de tes yeux de mes yeux
oui oui
j'ai tout eu de craquer quand je les ai
vus je trouve que tu as des yeux très
gentil il me rappelle un peu seul mon
père donc tu as passé la nuit avec moi
pour mes beaux yeux tu es gentil yeux
aussi c'était chouette de discuter avec
toi je te trouvais drôle sympathique et
ils avaient tous les jeux télé ça me
raccompagnait ça veut tout dire
ouais et une fois chez moi tu te montrer
si pour toi tu n'as rien tenté tu
restais là à me sourire puis tu m'a
remercié pour cette excellente soirée et
ensuite tu m'as dit bonne nuit
l'agencé hier j'ai dû réaliser que que
je voulais pas que la soirée saad là
avec le recul je réalise que j'aurais
mieux fait d'y mettre un terme plus tôt
trois minutes plus tôt si ma mémoire est
bonne d'ailleurs en parlant minute
mathieu est écoulé j'ai une grosse
journée qui m'attend demain à ce propos
tu t'es pas forcé de thé pas forcé de
m'accompagner
takm déposer l'argent est blessé
l'adresse demain matin j'ai dit que je
t'emmène chez un bon médecin je tien an
men d'accord ça veut dire que je m'en
charge en personne c'est pas nécessaire
tu sais je le ferai quand même du coup
on se retrouve à 13h45 devant l'hôpital
pims view à l'angle de la 39e rue et la
5e avenue ça ne va ok j'y serai
je te dis à demain alors merci pour le
cercle
[Musique]
en
oh
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous auriez une cigarette
allo ici c'est bobby j'ai un petit
problème
si j'ai bien suivi ton histoire table en
quête de l'argent dans son appartement
mais tu veux que ce soit moi qui aille
le chercher c'est ça parce que tu as
peur que ton proprio appelle les flics
site shop vu que tu lui doit plusieurs
mois de loyer toujours ça et donc tu me
demande de rentrer chez toi sans me
faire remarquer de récupérer l'argent et
veut faire passer pour la femme de
ménage si quelqu'un me surprend pas tout
compris oui et tu comptes faire avaler
cette histoire à kick
ouais t'as raison c'est pas crédible a
bien tu n'as qu'à et tu n'as qu'à dire
que tu rends visite attentes
non j'ai déjà utilisé ce à oreille puis
site si on se tient ce qu'on avait dit
tu es la femme de ménage ça va marcher
d'accord et si on pose la question tu ne
connais pas et tu ignores où on peut me
trouver c'est sûr que si je te connais
pas je peux pas savoir où tu es voilà
tout à fait pourquoi tu me dis pas tout
simplement la vérité tu sais tout ce que
tu dois savoir c'est vraiment mon
appartement ça ce sont mes clés et tu
dois reprendre mon fric tu te doutes
bien que si je pouvais y aller moi même
je le ferais non maintenant si tu ne
veux pas le faire c'est comme tu veux
c'est rien mais je n'ai pas d'argent
jeunesse cet endroit aurait
effectivement besoin d'une femme de
ménage
faux
[Musique]
c'est bon tu là
bien joué
les femmes sont le mal
écoute qui tombe mal mais que les chiens
en route pour tu vois
oui tu me raconteras comment ça se
termine très marrant
dis à tout le monde
c'est combien je suis de là s'il vous
plaît
regardez mantois du conte
bonjour le sia tôt de chez rendez vous
aux liens que leur maintenant en fait
merci rempli c'est ce qu'ont mis
d'accord
il me faut que mon permis à mon numéro
de sécu oui s'il vous plaît très bien
qu'est ce qui se passe je crois pas
avoir la force de le faire ça tombe bien
on te demandera pas de faire quoi que ce
soit
c'est à moi temps durs et toi tu en as
fait assez
non mais peut-être
peut-être qu'on pourrait attendre
attendre ouais quoi tu pourrais que si
je rentre chez moi et que je prends deux
aspirines ça va passer
je plaisante pas on devrait au moins en
parler toi tu la boucle est interdit de
jouer à ce jeu là ok j'ai pesé le pour
et le contre
j'ai passé des heures à me demander quoi
faire toi même tu m'a fait comprendre
que tant voulait pas et hier alors
signer son sens
je crois qu'on devrait attendre toi tu
crois qu'on devrait attendre
oui tu crois qu'on devrait être de voir
et je te déteste quand wade tête je me
tais toi si tu te plais sept mois
l'américain c'est vrai qu'on en parle on
passe devant on trouvera une solution
est-ce qu'on pourrait au moins ont
discuté calmement c'est que les forums
officiels de tu perds deux fois l'argent
jussiê je te demande de me faire
confiance là tout de suite
cours cours
[Musique]
tél
non
[Musique]
dépêche livia
desmarais fils merci
[Musique]
et là tu es déjà là tu es un peu en
avance j'avais bien dit à ta mère de
jean est pas le déjeuner n'est ce pas
ouais mais on était de passage dans le
quartier du coup je dois bas venez et
entrez donc ça lui en fait j'allais
descendre faire quelques courses à
l'épicerie dans ta mère elle m'a tout
noté sur une liste namer est pas là non
elle est allée au parc avec mes
petits-enfants
ma fille me confie la garde d'une fois
par semaine ils sont mignons mais qu'est
ce qu'ils sont chiants des jumeaux
et donc toi tu es sa petite amie non non
oui bah il faut que j'aille faire les
courses
vous faites quoi vous voulez venir et
quoi non non vous voulez rester ici oui
si cette voie on va attendre la mer très
bien c'est moi qui t'ai fait sa ba je
suis vraiment désolé je vais être franc
avec toi j'aime ta mère plus que tout et
je tiens vraiment à la protéger moi
aussi je m'appelle bobby connard tu
m'expliques quoi qu'est ce que tu veux
savoir
je sais pas quand on a dit rester chez
bordel pourquoi des policiers nous ont
pris en chasse comme ça dans quelle
galère mathieu embarqué pierre carles et
surtout qu'il tutoie registre girl est
le compagnon de ma mère elle vient
d'emménager ici avec lui je vois et
concernant les flics disons que je ne
travaille pas exactement où wall street
donc je peux exclure le délit d'initié
je suis un pickpocket
ça te fait marrer
un pickpocket oui voilà qui explique que
la moitié de la police de new york soit
à tous tiens au courant pour le fait qui
s'est fait piquer son badge
à
hu c'est génial vraiment j'attends
l'enfant d'un voleur qu'il faut chaud
vieille de leurs sacs à main et fait
jamais rien pris à ceux qui avaient
l'air d'avoir moins que moi c'est clair
en par dompter qu'un simple robin des
bois ça va tu connais rien de ma vie ok
c'est vrai tu as raison je sais rien à
ce sujet qu'est ce que tu racontes j'ai
pas changé je suis toujours le même mec
que tu as rencontré au bar sauf que je
fais pas le métier que tu croyais qu
est-ce qui va pas chez toi c'est pas un
métier ça body c'est du vol
à rennes on jette interdit de me juger
mon père m'a laissé cinq cent mille
dollars de dettes de jeu à rembourser et
une mère qui travaille pas quel autre
choix j'avais eu à temps pourquoi t'as
pas tout raconter à la bri parce qu'il a
menacé de tuer ma mère
pourquoi tu continues à voler
je lui dois encore cent mille dollars
environ
c'est bon qu'est ce que tu fais ça sauf
un je récupère l'argent je refuse de
mettre au monde un enfant si c'est pour
qu'il doive rendre visite à son père en
prison à chaque noël ou est-ce que tu
l'a mis il est dans ma veste
non il est pas
qu'est ce que tu racontes qui a rien là
dedans je le trouve pas qu'est ce que
t'en as fait tu l'a perdue ou quoi ne
mets pas ça sur le dos c'est toi qui
l'avais dans thales mais non rappelle
toi à l'hôpital tu l'a récupéré dans ma
poche servira pas content tu m'a attrapé
les bras tu m'embrasses et je te signal
peut-être qu'il est tombé dans le taxi
j'en sais rien ou alors quand ce type
t'es rentré dedans tout à l'heure
le coup classique le pickpocket s'est
fait faire les poches à son tour
celles ci ont les mains monsieur videz
vos poches et que ça si vous tenez à la
vie vous avez trop tard bobby était déjà
là mais oui car dans l'épicerie aller
jouer avec vos hamster vous deux bonjour
je suis la mère de bobby et rita à lui
les six mois je me souviens pas de la
dernière fois que bobby a ramené une
fille à la maison me la présentez vous
devez être elle allait partir maman elle
doit s'en aller ce n'est qu'une copine
je passe te voir plus tard d'accord faut
qu'on reparle de nom mais à temps et de
manière peut-être qu'elle voudrait dire
que j'allais nous préparer des lasagnes
c'est le plat préféré de bobby salaires
bon je serais ravi tous les six oui
génial fils en cuisine
ok je vais vous donner un coup de main à
son fonctionnement je portais battant ne
dit rien à ma mère s'il te plait bien
sûr que non je voudrais pas contrarier
mamie
monsieur vous voulez jouer un jeu de
société avec nous non un jeu vidéo non
aux gendarmes et aux voleurs alors
encore moins
alors comment tu as connu bobby premiers
mois on a un ami commun la
je crois qu'il est plus qu il ne veut
l'avouer qu'est ce qui vous fait dire ça
aux quand il est en présence d'une fille
qui lui plaît vraiment il est toujours
sur les nerfs
à croire qu'il ne veut pas lui montrer
qu'il s'intéresse à elle je sais comment
sont les gars ont toujours attiré les
nappes défi pour retenir leur attention
c'est quoi le cap non le craps si le nom
du jeu et attention c'est un jeu très
sérieux si vous faites un sétois 11 au
premier jet vous gagnez en revanche si
vous faites 2 3 ou 12 s'est perdue le
reste 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
ça devient le nombre de points celui qui
vous faut obtenir pour gagner sa gaffe
si vous faites un set au tour suivant
vous êtes éliminés c'est clair ni qui tu
commences non non non attendez il faut
d'abord parier allez les gars on placer
vos mises
voilà ça y est tu peux lancer les dés
alors 1,4 c'est ce qu'on appelle un
little joe maintenant si tu veux gagner
tu dois refaire un cadre d'accord moi ce
que j'aime faire s'essouffler sur les d
donnez-moi little joe aller un little
joy radio j'ai gagné non non non tu as
perdu tu perds ton tour et nous on
récupère thébaux bon peu tu pas ce qui
se passe quand on parie attentes indiqué
m dames ça vous tente pas peu d'action
venez jouer avec nous non ça ira j'ai eu
ma dose d'action pour aujourd'hui
merci c'est moi j'apporte le fromage et
les tomates fraîches salué sans fil vrai
que ça se passe laissez moi j'ai cédé
non non t'inquiète je gère depuis mai
casas et saucats ça et surtout ça me
donne une bonne excuse pour aller
rejoindre la plus belle femme du monde
en cuisine
bonjour ma chérie mon nom de jésus nous
te prions amen amen
année
alors pub d'après ce que m'a dit ta mère
tu travaille dans la finance
oui et comment ça se passe pour toi
il ya des hauts et des bas j'avais cru
comprendre que tu avais du mal à payer
son loyer ces derniers temps si tu as
besoin d'un emploi stable à jour
n'hésite surtout pas venir me voir
t'as qu'à m'appeler car tient une
bijouterie en centre vivent les diamants
sont les meilleurs amis d'une femme
un papy wii ne jamais acheter au détail
ont c'est bon à savoir
tu sais bobby si par hasard tu connais
quelqu'un qui a envie d'acheter jolie
bague de fiançailles tâche dans un cadre
où il fera un bon prix merci maman si
c'est ce que les six faits dans la vie
une photographe professionnelle un non
chevrette je fais ça en freelance et en
réalité je travaille à mi temps dans un
bar en ce moment vous savez ce que c'est
ça fait mal mais c'est une façon honnête
et nous a dit je ne dirait pas le
contraire
et pareil tu viens du texas d'ailleurs
j'y retourne samedi prochain je rentre
chez toi
oui rien n'est encore fixé mais en tout
cas je serai en ménage avec ma soeur je
vais essayer de trouver un job dans un
studio photo y faire des portraits ce
genre de choses
tu as prévu de me voir les camps de ce
projet à vrai dire c'est ma vie je vois
pas en quoi ça nous concerne
elles sont commencés la série moi
j'adore ces délicieux excellente pardon
excusez moi tu veux à l'etrat fraîchir
non si tu veux je peux tu accompagnes à
la salle de bain si tu te sens pas
traquer ce cas qu'est-ce qui se passe
à l'évidence vous respire je suis pas en
train d'accoucher cet abruti s'ils
ressentent de trois mois seulement
habib maman [ __ ] coeur
pourquoi tu ne m'a rien dit
j'en sais rien
je voulais pas l'inquiéter pourquoi ça
m'inquiéterait en quoi la possibilité de
devenir grand mère devrait m'inquiéter
elle veut le garder
j'en sais rien
est-ce que tulle m
mais qu'est ce que j'en sais maman je
veux dire
j'y connais rien à l'amour comment on
peut savoir et bien déjà tu t'es senti
comment quand elle a annoncé qu'elle
rentrait samedi au texas et curé
et dans l'ambulance sur le chemin de
l'hôpital qu'est-ce que tu ressortait
[Musique]
l'homme est ainsi fait que parfois il
faut qu'ils manquent de tout perdre pour
prendre enfin conscience de la chance
qu'il a
ma coiffeuse je vais mettre en route
je vais vous laisser tous les deux
salut
saleh
le docteur a dit d'aller en remettre
c'est rien selon lui tu as seulement
besoin de repos
comment faire le pb
il est en parfaite santé
quoi t'inquiète pas ça va aller dans
quelques jours ce sera oublié
profond je respirais direction sur tout
seul
seulement je sais toujours pas ce que je
vais faire non ce qu'on va faire
maintenant tu n'es plus seul c'est fini
on est deux d'accord je ne dis pas
n'importe quoi
tu veux pas avoir d'enfant
pour se connaît à peine enfin tu te
rappelles même pas mon nom il ya
seulement quelques jours c'était
vraiment ce que tu crois que je me
souvenais pas de comment tu t'appelais
tu veux savoir la vérité
oui
ce serait bien pour une fois
ok
oui d'accord
après cette nuit là j'ai je n'arrêtais
pas de penser à toi
je pensais tellement à toi que ça me
rendait dingue et puis quand j'étais
enfin sorti de ma tête mais tu étais là
juste devant moi
je n'arrivais plus à aligner deux mots
temps j'étais nerveux
pourquoi tu m'a pas appelé
et j'avais la trouille
quand je me suis réveillé ce matin là
j'étais regarder dormir tu étais
tellement belle
tu es magnifique
je n'avais aucune envie de te quitter
je t'assure avant toi ça m'était jamais
arrivé j'ai pris un bout de papier pour
te laisser mon numéro mais je n'ai pas
pu j'ai chiffonné la feuille et puis
j'ai noté un faux numéros à la place
ensuite j'ai réécrit mon vrai numéro je
les relis faux nez et ainsi de suite
j'ai dû faire ça j'ai pas une dizaine de
fois au bout du compte j'ai ramassé tous
les morceaux de papier pour les fourrés
dans ma poche avant de partir j'en ai
pioché au hasard et je me suis dit et si
c'est pas le bon numéro c'est que ça
doit pas se faire
laissons le destin en décide et je sais
je suis un connard j'ai été stupide je
les regrettés à un point que tu imagines
même pas
je n'avais pas oublié ton nom du si loin
de là je n'ai pas réussi et j'ai essayé
et tu peux me croire
tu as déjà partie pourquoi je te crois
ça fait trois mois que je la trimballe
dans mon portefeuille j'ai des problèmes
avec l'engagement ça j'avais vu
tu peux même pas rester fidèle à une
marque de cigarettes je ne vais pas fuir
cette fois tu entends je reste
je veux prendre cet engagement je peux
pas être avec quelqu'un qui vole pour
vivre
alors c'est terminé j'arrête le vol à la
tire donne moi une chose je te
prouverait que je peux changer si tu
m'en laisse la chance et tu vas arrêter
tu peux arrêter comme ça quand sûrs pour
moi
coucou
didon ça suffit vous deux prenez une
chambre
c'est terminé pour aujourd'hui et vous
vous avez besoin de repos
vous
[Musique]
et
mais je savais que les flics jaxx
tu est de mèche avec la police toi ta
gueule je devrais être buté sur le champ
comment tu as pu me balancer après tout
ce temps t'es pas mon pote
j'ai sacrifié pour toi jack skille j'ai
sacrifié ma vie pour toi comment tu as
pu faire rien du tout pour moi tu piges
fallait pas [ __ ] la merde dans mes
affaires
tu as volé le patch d'un flic est ce que
tu en as tirer de l'argent non au lieu
de ça les flics ont débarqué chez moi
chez moi tu travailles pour moi
maintenant ça te fait rien et ça tu
trouve ça marrant de tête je l'aurais
dit ou tu habitais je leur ai dit où
trouver et quand il serait tu as payé un
gars pour me tirer mon fric ouais mais
je me doutais que tu aurais du liquide
sur toi monsieur moralité t'avais merdé
avec ta copine talent est forcément
vouloir assumer d'autant qu'à la panhard
on t'as de la veine mon ami tu as rendu
service
c'est lui qui m'a de nos flics comme moi
non durex
est ce que je me suis énervé contre lui
non
tu sais pourquoi parce que c'est comme
ça que ça marche c'est du business
ça a rien de personnel
c'est fini
à temps
at on écoute passé - ian o'sullivan et
si je pouvais 30 et 50 mille dollars +
tout ce que je te dois non c'est trop
tard ok tu sais quoi tu veux appeler les
flics appelle les flics qui sauront rien
contre moi là je n'ai pas le badge
tu sais comme moi que son image disons
rien verrou inaporc ils ont rien tant la
partie est finie
j'ai découvert un [ __ ] de film ça va
être apporté tellement que tu pour
arrêter tes combinat de balle tu aimes
les diamants j'étais content ça
intéresse du lourd je vais te fournir un
paquet de diamant
pavy quoique salut comment tu te sens je
me sens beaucoup mieux
c'est bien je devrais pouvoir rentrer
chez moi cet après midi le médecin
préfère attendre les derniers résultats
d'analysé pour être sûr mais toi ça a
pas l'air d'aller
aussi si ça
elles sont pour moi oh ouais désolé
merci d'écouter ou si je sais qu'hier je
t'ai dit que j'allais arrêter ce que je
fais mais il s'est passé un truc c'est
le bordel et du coup il ya une dernière
chose que je dois régler une toute
dernière de quoi est-ce que tu pas
comment dire en réalité c'est un peu
compliqué et confiance en moi c'est tout
ce que je te demande
la seule raison pour laquelle je te
parle de tout ça c'est parce que je veux
être honnête avec toi être honnête avec
moi tu ne m'a même pas donner un début
d'explication
je sais j'ai rien droit de dire et
j'aimerais pourtant de mettre au courant
si tu essaies tu t'en fuir ou pire que
tu en parles je jure devant dieu que je
te ferai la peau
ensuite ce sera son tour à elle je te le
jure
après demain tout sera terminé j'en
aurai fini avec mon ancienne vie dommage
ça marcherait plus là j'ai un avion à
prendre un billet accorde moi une
journée là d'accord je t'expliquerai
tout après
je t'aime
allez au carl
c'est bobby
écoute j'aurai besoin d'un service
navré on est fermé je suis la mine bobby
ah oui bien sûr
il avait prévenu pouvait nier je vous en
prie entre et moi c'est carl carmoni
enchanté données je m'excuse pour leur
teint je viens à peine de sortir du bon
ben on savait rien alors bobine a
expliqué rapidement que vous travaillez
ensemble à wall street
non non non moi je suis son patron et
alors vous cherchez bague de fiançailles
si j'ai bien compris inexactes je vais
être honnête avec vous j'y connais rien
aux bijoux mais alors strictement rien
gens portent jamais une vraie je ne vous
en tiendrai pas rigueur
mais ma fiancée c'est tout l'inversé
elle a même des goûts de luxe et je le
lui offrir un bijou sans tuer vous avez
un budget combien je peux me permettre
environ sur un an 2000 $ si je peux
avoir un truc bien à ce prix 1 30 mille
dollars et bien oui vous devez très bien
gagner votre vie soit je me débrouille
très bien
je reviens ne bougeait pas j'ai ici des
diamants de kara et demi ou trois quarts
de pureté vvs un ou deux selon les
anneaux et comme on peut le voir de
couleur gît dans l'ensemble et c'est une
bague de fiançailles ça aussi oui c'est
l'un de ces diamants vous tape dans
l'oeil mais que vous avez un doute sur
la monture elle a peut-être une bague
qui appartenait à sa mère sur laquelle
elle voudrait sortir la pierre je sais
vous savez qu'il fallait le faire
d'où cette organisation pour le mariage
ça me stresse c'est dingue
moi je pensais qu'il y avait qu une
sorte de bague de fiançailles j'aurais
pas imaginer qu'il y avait tant de
styles différents
vous ne voulez pas faire du repérage
d'abord vous faites un tour des
bijouteries à égal par exemple ce week
end
et puis dès qu'elle est vous avez une
idée plus précise de ce que vous voulez
vous revenez me voir le truc c'est que
je reçois du monde chez moi aujourd'hui
est que j'aurais espéré enfin que
j'avais prévu de
de lui offrir là bas que ce soit en plus
ça va être une grosse fête j'ai déjà
commandé leurs parents oui je ne peux
pas les sortir d'ici voilà ce que je
vous propose
j'ai ici quinze mille dollars en liquide
c'était pas une question d'argent avant
de refuser que nous devons à ce qu'elle
a à dire je vous vers cette somme en
acompte vous faites une sélection alors
peu importe vous prenez celle qui selon
vous lui plairait et moi je les emmène
chez moi c'était de me dégoûter je veux
bien vous aider je sais bien que vous
êtes l'ami de pop c'est vous qui
choisissez donc elles peuvent lui
convenir et qu'on reste dans la gamme de
prix
bon je vous paie la différence en
liquide une fois là bas attendez vous
l'avenir
il ya plus d'un demi million de dollars
entièrement là si vous le souhaitez je
vous fais tout de suite un check in or
la bestialité j'aime pas sortir les
diamants de boutiques
je vous dis que j'ai assez liquide chez
moi pour régler la différence pour vous
c'est une vente assurée à mon avis ne
faudra pas de seconde pour décider je
parie même qu'elle va choisir la plus
chère c'est bien parce que vous êtes la
vie publique j'accepte de prendre votre
argent
donnez-moi deux minutes pour le mettre
dans le coffre et on pourra les la
surprendre vous ne préférez pas que je
règle le tout en une fois non ça ne va
pas faire que vous avez dit
sinon je peux aussi garder le liquide
sur moi et je vous paye la bac compte en
tout à l'heure mais déjà un gros effort
en consentant à vous sortir les diamants
d'ici et j'aime mieux savoir où quinze
mille dollars us
c'est sûr parce que ça me gêne pas de
payer tout d'un coup oui oui je suis sûr
et tiens d'ailleurs en prime permettez
moi de vous faire cadeau de cette paire
de boucles d'oreilles qui sont
absolument ravissante
[Musique]
voilà c'est bon c'est vrai
je
[Musique]
ce quartier me rappelle des souvenirs
dit je peux vous demander un service je
voudrais rappeler qu'il fait pour être
sûr qu'elle est rentrée nation
hier j'étais aux toilettes et j'y fais
ton
lien
bloomberg a fait tomber ses clés
[Musique]
sans combat vous avez le temps de voir
de tels types à ces mois-là policiers
oui
oui j'aime dans l'assistance je rêve
allô oui on vient de le dévaliser dans
west broadway
celle ci lui dites leur qu'ils avaient
une veste verte
il portait une veste verte qui était un
bébé est offerte utilitaires et des
cheveux blonds euros j'avais toute ma
vie dans cette analyse est ce que je
vais devenir
tu m'en veut parce qu'il s'est passé
quand pète plus d'un demi million de
dollars en diamants et en cash
je suis vraiment désolé je n'ai pas vu
venir arrivé en trombe ça a été trop
vite vous allez bien vous faites ça va
aller
oui ça va sinon rien je suis vraiment
désolé j'ai l'impression c'est ma faute
et je m'en veux terriblement
mais vous en faites pas je suis persuadé
que les flics vont le retrouver ils vont
ainsi voulu en être sûr te voilà enfin
et tu t'es vous porter ça fait des
plombes qu'on attend il eut tout près de
me demander de la compagnie au
commissariat pour témoigner et moi
j'étais là je peux pas je voudrais bien
je suis déjà en retard ma fiancée matin
on vraiment que je fige et prétendantes
à financer sa fille j'avais pas qu'on
était ensemble très drôle ou et bobby il
est pas la presse que tu fabriques
je croyais qu'on attendait que tout le
monde cela pour l'ouvrir écoute moi bien
bobby aura que dalle c'est clair toi je
te filerai un anneau et après c'est fini
on ferme boutique de nyon ça tu ferme
boutique la porte mais tu vas aller où
comme si j'allais le dire non
[Musique]
follis tout le monde à terre les mains
derrière la tête
ça va non
cool
quelle marque je sais pas
c'est une cigarette
j'ai arrêté
de fumée bleue vols à la tire
les deux
qu'est ce que c'est
je me serais volontiers mis à genoux
mais je suis assis au milieu des ordures
j'ai peur que ce soit pas des plus
romantiques
c'est pas une bonne volée lors de ton
dernier 15 par hasard
karl m'a proposé une affaire en or
il m'a même fait une sacrée réduc
plus si je suis au courant
karl est venu me rendre visite à
l'hôpital il m'a expliqué ce que vos
manigances y est
attends tu savais tu as quand même
laissé gomer de passer à tabac oui et ça
m'a mis un peu en rogne que ce soit pas
toi qui me le dise
il a bien fait ça t'a pas vous
si on est sûr
non
et donc
il se passe quoi maintenant
ma maman
sous
marcel à ma place
inga tomber dans une question c'est bien
sûr
vous avez des médias
ça
[Musique]
à demain soir à toulouse
misère
[Musique]
au but
l'avocat
[Musique]
c'est eux
l'agencé